the agenda is set i break off in berlin
it's time to talk
make them leave or let them stay
the new face of france's immigration
debate
politics and lobbyists here in germany
are they writing laws by writing checks
and putting on the world cup in qatar
just how high is the human cost
welcome to the show everybody i've
invited three people today to talk argue
and pry apart these headlines my first
guest just returned from qatar he's a
journalist who wanted to report on
working conditions at world cup
construction sites that however got him
arrested i'm happy of course to be able
to welcome him today on the show peter
giesel is with us today peter you are
with us you are a free man we can say
and um you're going to tell us your
story shortly it's good to have you on
the show today
my second guest always has his eye on
the thousands of lobbyists who work here
in berlin
in fact he gives tours in the city to
show the public just where the lobbyists
headquarters are located i'm happy to
welcome to the show timo longa timo
you're with lobby control that's an
initiative that pushes for more
transparency
in democracy such as germany good to
have you on the show today
and my next guest ensures
that roma from across europe get legal
advice and counsel he is the executive
director at the european roma rights
center in budapest i'm happy to welcome
to the show
desi dairyu gargay
it's good to have you on the show
disadero
let me begin by
getting your reaction to what france's
interior minister said recently he said
that the majority of roma migrants who
are in france illegally
will never integrate
into french society is
their aroma problem
in france
let me tell you that these statements
are not surprising if you look overall
into the
french policy towards
roma migrants in france we can see that
there's an ongoing attention from the
state administration towards the roma
and this started a few years ago with
the previous administration where roma
exactly when roma from eu countries have
been returned to the countries to their
countries of origins and that was
accompanied by by
high officials
stating
that returns and explosions needs to
start with the roma
now that basically pointed out a state
policy which looked into pinpoint a
group that continued unfortunately with
the current administration in france all
right let me just put everybody in here
for a second timo and peter do you guys
do you see
france and maybe even the german
government targeting
the gypsies as they're also known is it
are they just an easy target when we're
talking about finding people who are in
the country illegally well you know
germans don't know enough
about them i think that's the bottom
line you know when i grew up
we grew up with
about gypsies uh you know living a funny
life
and um it's something i just had to read
out of the child's book for my own
daughter who's four years old so that's
basically uh
the image of them that we have it's not
no not enough information to be honest
we had in germany also this debate about
roma
that fled from the war in in kosovo and
then they had to be returned and
the conditions in kosovo are not so easy
for roma and that's something the german
government didn't take into account
properly i think and i'm just wondering
how can a french minister make such a
statement never going to to integrate
that's
such a strong argument i think what is
problematic here that it is that we have
a state official which is basically
reinforcing misconceptions and
misperceptions about a group based on
the fact that the group basically
doesn't share values therefore the
solution is that they should be placed
somewhere else not in the society where
the truth
let me pick up on that um it's a good
point that you make um the the french
are
asking themselves um where in our
society do the roma belong do they
belong as you said at all in france
in paris a group of more than 25 roma
was just convicted of forcing children
to steal now it was revealed that the
children were stealing up to 6 000 euros
a month at the top of this network was a
66 year old grandmother now the defense
attorney took an unexpected approach
arguing that the culture and the
traditions of the roma are centuries old
and one of them being survival the
implication here is that the roma people
are different they are you could say the
nomads of europe well that way of
thinking did not help matters this month
when french authorities deported a roma
family to kosovo including a young girl
who was attending a french school
students turned out in more than 20
french cities last weekend to protest
the deportation of a 15-year-old school
girl
a roma immigrant leonardo dibrani was
detained by police during a school field
trip and deported with her family to
kosovo
the move sparked a series of
demonstrations all over the country and
some of the protests led to clashes with
police
french president francois hollande
quickly said dubrani could return to
france to continue her studies if she
wished but that her family would not be
allowed back
the interior minister insists france has
to take a tough stance on immigration
polls show that around three quarters of
the people in france agree
the girl has refused to leave her family
behind in kosovo last year france
deported over 36 000 immigrants many of
them roma 12 percent more than in 2011.
so is french policy towards its roma
residents growing more inhumane
what do you say to that i just wanted to
react to what you call the defense
attorney strategy
i would i would from the scratch
reject such a
strategy first of all because there's
indication and there's research that
criminality is not related to ethnic
background
secondly there is no indication that the
cultural element in the case of the roma
would be
favorable for committing crimes we are
talking here about trafficking you
mentioned trafficking the european
rumoured center had a research done in
five countries across europe and what we
concluded the uh of course talking with
the roma and not only with the roma but
also with state agencies was that the
factors which uh
pulling if you want roma into
trafficking phenomenons are not related
to ethnicity at all or to cultural
behavior at all but they are related to
related to objective factors such as
very low
income very low uh economical means to
leave very low level of education and
from from there
this this vulnerability basically is
used by others
to get these people
this makes sense but um
a lot of people are going to look at the
demographics of europe and they're going
to ask how did the roma miss the
education trade the roma have been in
europe as long as anyone else has so why
is the roma group when you look at the
numbers
sometimes you have in some states you
have 50 to 80 percent of the people
without even um a primary school
education why
that's they can't blame that on the
state can you we we have to look in both
sides
let me tell you first of all that we are
talking about governmental attention to
the to the roma communities across
europe only for recent years so it is
true rome are here for for hundreds of
years but there was no attention giving
to the roma in terms of supporting them
to overcome the challenges they faced it
is only from 2001 central eastern
european governments they decided okay
we have to do something yeah so this uh
first of all as you say it's not a
one-sided
action it is a two-sided action so
it is a shared responsibility if you
want on one hand it is important to say
that yes roma need to send their
children to school not to the street and
it is very important to have that in
short but the roma need also support to
ensure that if you are living in an
extreme poverty and you don't have
support how can you keep your child in
school if you don't have proper housing
if you live in with your family let's
say 10 members in a room
would be your children able to learn and
to study effectively if you don't have
the means
to give them the food would you be able
to have it in school or or the closing
and so forth so there's a vicious circle
around this issue so for example when we
talk about the poverty which roma are
facing we cannot look only into one
angle yeah so this is not about giving
incentive financial incentives to roma
and then we solve the problem no it is
very complex because you have to look
into housing into employment into health
services and education so they are all
combined and that the states were not
able to break and to address it through
this
complex way you know when you talk about
what's going on in france right now um
we hear a lot of politicians but we we
hear just people in the public sphere
talking about the romas we're talking
about the gypsies um but we were talking
before the show if if you were walking
down the street here in europe um would
you be able to say that person is a roma
and say that person is not a german or
that person is not french and most
people said the answer would be no
we can't tell the difference
um and if you take that another step
shouldn't it make it then easier for the
roma to integrate in society or am i
making it too easy as long as
if
if it's their wish to do so uh i think
even in germany they they might be and
i'm talking might be they're able to do
so
but the the impression and the the image
this group has especially here in berlin
and in germany is a bad one just to put
it simply as it is you know
it's a pity
and i can hardly see any way of changing
it
do they want to do
i mean i'm not asking you to speak for
all roma but
can you say the lion's share of people
who say they are roma want to be a part
of the greater society that they are
living in i can tell you that every roma
wants to live
a decent life
and you know to have its family having a
decent life and kids into the school no
one wants to live on streets no one
wants to live by begging and by being
trafficked
that's for sure that's i can tell you
and in germany we have this problem as
well with other people from from the
mediterranean from from the middle east
who came here and now um yeah have to
integrate in the society and we had a
big discussion going on about parallel
societies and and i always felt this was
also stigmatizing all sorts of groups of
people um saying okay they don't really
want to to integrate but you also always
have to look at the other side and ask
what what are we doing as a society to
give the opportunity to
not discriminate this ethnic groups and
i think the roma are facing
discrimination in a lot of
european countries and that's also part
of the problem if you feel
the society in your country doesn't
really want you
it's a really really big step to to
change this and say okay now i'm
going towards this
society that obviously rejects me i
think it's also about
how open societies are to accommodate
diversity if you have a strong position
which says if you don't share our values
get out
that that's not the way to accommodate
diversity that's a way to impose your
own position and i wouldn't think
berliner especially berlin is a big big
scene
if we're talking about germany you
should think that this is an open-minded
society but apparently in the case of
the cindy aroma it apparently is not you
know there's a lot of there's a lot of
you know if you have looked at about the
npd
when they did the campaign right
the far right the fire party they had
banners out on the street saying uh
libra gate for the omaha
synth
get the money to my grandma uh
instead of the gypsies which is a very
aggressive point to make and you know
but you can't but you can't you can't
claim you know you can't say that the
french
are are doing that i mean the interior
minister has a valid point the people
that are being deported are in france
illegally
these are people that are not so much we
are looking at to this statement are we
talking about non-eu citizens eu
citizens i'm talking about non-eu
citizens there but also france also
reserves the right for everyone in the
shang agreement if you
move to france after three months
obviously you have to be properly
registered so the state has a
responsibility to enforce those laws
wouldn't you agree absolutely of course
i agree with this i cannot disagree it's
about the rule of law it is also about
how you implement the rule of law and
whether you consider
individual cases when you implement rule
of law and i mean here exactly
proportionality on implementing the law
and this case which we are which you you
just presented also is about
proportionality at the end of the day as
as many other cases which are related to
roma coming from eu member states and
they are also sent back to their
countries without any consideration of
their individual situation and this case
also in my point of view raises the
question on how authorities are
considering a particular case and
whether there is a proportionality when
they
put the law in practice because in this
case what we knew is we have a family
outside eu that went to a process
the application was rejected
twice and then the the order for
expulsion had to be put in place yeah
and we might the way this order was put
in place by state authorities raised the
public concern right and that was
related to proportionality but we also
know for example the school teacher she
also tried to intervene she tried to to
stop or slow things down because she
didn't want the little girl obviously to
be
traumatized how does the roma community
get more people like you
you
you know you're what the people need
but obviously there aren't enough of you
no absolutely i i fully get your point
this is about balancing out the negative
image and the negative perception which
roma have with with a positive
perception and a positive picture
because you know the story about roma is
not about failure it's not only about
you know people settling nearby bridges
and everything that but for people who
have always heard you know these stories
um tell us just very briefly what in
your life in your childhood from your
parents what happened that allowed you
obviously you know to become an attorney
um that didn't allow you to become what
so many people think the stereotype is
it was the my parents will and sacrifice
to have me educated my my father is a
roma musician and he didn't want me to
study music he wanted me to study law
because he said you have to overcome
what i faced you have to not to face the
same level of discrimination which i
faced so for them that was top priority
i go to study i
will be a lawyer and i will have a
different
pattern in life but becoming a lawyer
didn't mean um losing your sense of
being around absolutely
absolutely
okay good we're going to move on we're
going to go from identity
to money and politics
can you put a price on influence
lobbyists as we all know attempt to do
that every day it can be something as
normal as inviting a lawmaker for a cup
of coffee or it can be something
anything but normal and that brings us
here to germany the family which owns
the luxury car maker bmw transferred 690
000 euros to the cdu party earlier this
month the cdu party of course this is
the party in power it's the party of the
german chancellor angela merkel now at
the same time germany blocked an eu plan
calling for tougher limits on car
emissions you probably see the
connection there well opposition parties
and ngos say that the time has come to
fix a system that is supposed to
regulate contributions to political
parties and they claim that the rules
today allow interest groups with deep
pockets
to easily assume the power of policy
makers
germany is an industrial powerhouse and
chancellor angela merkel is often seen
together with the heads of those
industries
one example merkel appears to see
supporting cars made in germany as part
of her role
but revelations of a 690 000 euro
donation by the quant industrial dynasty
to merkel's party have again raised
concerns of undue influence on
government policy
did the hefty donation from the family
behind bmw have any bearing on
environmental policy
the donation was made close to a key
decision by eu environmental ministers
in luxembourg
in the debate germany has lobbied
against tighter controls on emissions
from cars
the cdu says it has been completely open
and every german political party
receives similar donations
the bmw payment is listed on the
bundestag's website along with many
others
but critics and transparency watchdogs
say there are still not enough controls
on donations to parties in germany
it looks like everything's fine the
money that's given to political parties
is registered it's put up for public
notice we know where the money is coming
from
so what's the problem
well angela merkel obviously now acts
like she's the chief lobbyist of the
automotive industry in germany and it's
not very easy to say okay she does this
because of the contributions of bmw and
other car manufacturers but it always is
a delicate question when money comes to
politics and
the question
every citizen in this country us or in
europe um how much influence has this
money really got how how much can you
influence a political decision with uh
donations and i think you cannot uh
answer that very easily were you
convinced though that if
the money had not come from bmw are you
do you think that the
decision
in the european apartment or the
european commission about the car
emissions rule do you think it would
have been different
you cannot uh
put a link make up a link between this
single donation and and the uh policy of
the german government that's what
everyone's doing right now you have to
look at the bigger picture and
see that the car industry is one of the
biggest
contributors to german political parties
or the biggest
even in the long long term if you look
at a couple of years it's not the first
contribution that came from this quant
family
and what's peculiar about this case is
that
the contribution was made after
the election after the election campaign
and the quan family said okay but we
said to the cdu uh in spring already
that we want to give
them this campaign
contribution which is which it is in
fact so the cdu
um
they worked with this money kind of and
received it after the election so
so people could not see this
contribution it's an advantage it's an
advanced payment though i mean
is there any way
to question or find out if
bmw did get some type of of a benefit by
promising that money
so early
that's i mean we're talking about
transparency right we're talking about
transparency and then we certainly need
more transparency for example we know
that the car manufacturers and bmw
themselves are lobbying quite intensely
on
co2 regulations and and other things and
we don't know a lot about
who is lobbying here in berlin because
we have no
lobbying transparency no mandatory
lobbying transparency and that's
also one issue that that we need to
address also to put this
donation this contribution into
perspective
and
yeah it's a
kind of a tricky question on the one
hand you say okay you can't prove a
direct link between this contribution
and a political decision that has been
made but on the other hand you have to
say okay there might be influence and
how this influence exactly um works out
that's something that only the cdu
themselves are missing the obvious here
i mean what's the use in payments like
this yeah it is some
in the magnitude exactly hundreds of
thousands if it wasn't for any kind of
you know return i'm not talking about a
gift but there has to be something
coming back for the money i mean at
least what the donors expect they want
to buy influence
if they get it in the end that's that's
not sure it's kind of an investment but
it's a good investment if if i give you
700 000 euros as opposed to 5 000 euros
right that's certainly a good investment
yeah i mean
would you say i mean i don't want to
take it too political but when you look
at this angel america the chancellor and
the cdu
um they have a price don't they
well it's uh
journalists always want to know can you
buy a politician but if you say okay you
can
then that's a very very serious
allegation i mean you you would uh
say angela merkel you can buy her that's
that's corruption that would be uh
but turn it around why aren't people
angry about a car company giving that
much money to a political party i mean
that that smells fishy it smells fishy i
mean or am i the only one you know it
smells fishy you gotta be used to it
haven't they you know it's been a part
of germany's political culture
throughout the last decades and that the
corporate sector and not we're not only
talking bmw we're talking mercedes linde
big gas
production company they've they've all
been paying you know it's it's something
that has been not only part of the
german political culture but i think in
other eu countries as well right i mean
we as a matter of principle for me as a
citizen i would say that what would
prevail is accountability and integrity
so i think first of all in in a
situation like this i think someone
would have to have an explanation for
the public first of all to say what is
that about
secondly in terms of integrity i think
it's about the conflict of interest is
there a conflict of interest or is not
and i think that also requires an
explanation for the public because there
should be a justification
in terms of weighing the public interest
into a matter which is
emissions seo emissions and a private
agenda which is a company so how you
weighed in these two interests and and
where the politician stands and how it
balances out these two interests through
incentives
but isn't the the easy solution here
just um to restrict the amount of
contributions to something like
something like a thousand euros wouldn't
that fix the problem well it'll kill the
parties uh operation ability you know
they wouldn't be able to do their work
anymore i think they're being financed
uh in a part of one-third by the
corporate sector is that right that
depends on the party if you look at
the cdu they get approximately one
quarter or one-third
in contributions the other parts are
coming from from the state that state
funding for political parties and
membership fees and one so one let's say
one quarter is what the cdu gets from
contributions if you look at the the
left party they get
below one percent of contributions from
from legal persons so from associations
and corporations the social democrats
they got in back in 2009 the last
election year
2.5 percent approximately from legal uh
persons
so
that's a big difference for them and if
you then look at the political parties
those that almost get none
uh contributions from uh companies from
from association they say okay
no they are sometimes in power if they
get into power then they can get more
contributions as well but but they it's
very easy for them to say okay let's ban
all those
corporate contributions and but i would
say yes it would be a good approach to
say we need a upper limit
to cap those
those donations is there is there the
willingness to do that now you know the
uh the german parliament convenes this
week today um
exactly i mean this show you know uh may
be shown on wednesday too but it's
happening this week
um
and we're talking about a possible
government between the cdu the spd this
this grand coalition if the if these big
parties are going to be embedded
together yeah
is there going to be any drive
whatsoever to change things
that's a very good question i'm hoping
that the social democrats
will be sticking to to their agenda what
they said
in their election campaign is we want to
curb the power the influence of
lobbyists and also we want to cap the
donation
to political parties social democrats
say hundred thousand per dona per year
should be enough
so
that's 1 000
euros per person
per year
that's still a lot i mean of course
that's still that's still politics for
the you know the rich and glam yeah it
is but it is it is a cap and what we
need
further than that is more transparency i
mean right now we have those fifth this
50 000 threshold only if a single
donation is larger than 50 000 it gets
publicized right away
and that's also something that the
council of europe the group of state
against corruption is saying to germany
you need to do something about this this
is a problem
okay there are problems in other
countries as well but but this group of
state against corruption is now
demanding from germany you need to
change the transparency of of party
funding you need to improve this and
germany so far has refused to do this
and it's an interesting question how the
next government will address those
issues yeah
i think there's another question here
that's all when you when you see this uh
huge amounts of money is is how does
money are used and for what purpose
exactly and i think for the public
there's a there's a point here to know
how are this money used as a matter of
fact
is is there's any possibility to track
down i'm going to what would a political
party i want to read something to you
that's a good point um all party
donations
um are currently governed by a law that
was reformed in 2011.
and the law decreed that the parties
decide themselves
how their state contributions will be
measured and they set their own limits
on donations from companies and private
individuals that means the political
parties in germany they basically do as
they please
which means
either
the people are incredibly trusting or
incredibly naive
so what is it yeah i mean the people
they
after each scandal that that we gathered
there have been scandals in this country
almost every every year we have some
kind of
fishy party funding or uh other
type of scandal and people lose
confidence in the political elites and
the political parties and that's i think
one reason why why the participation in
the election is going down continuously
because people think okay if you got a
lot of money you can
by in a
broader sense
policies if not through party donations
you can hire high public officials and
and uh employ them as a company what
we've seen recently uh
member of mr merkel's cabinet they are
going to be going to be the new chief
lobbyists of of daimler
remember
yeah he ruined his political legislation
with this type of thing so it's going to
be staying i think yeah yeah all right
last election we had had the liberal
party also receiving a big donation and
yeah from the whole everyone likes money
i i think we all agree with that
everyone likes yeah and we probably
won't see a big change anytime soon but
speaking of money that's going to take
us um to the world of soccer
the soccer world cup in 2022 will take
place in qatar
now more than a million migrant workers
have flooded into the country they are
part of the 100 billion euro
construction boom that is underway there
right now the british newspaper the
guardian reported last month that those
workers have become world cup slaves
working and living conditions so poor
that thousands are expected to die on
the job before any game is played qatari
officials have rejected these claims we
want to ask today are those officials
willing to let the truth be told
after qatar won its bid to host the 2022
world cup soccer tournament a country
already in the midst of a building boom
went into overdrive
but amid its race to host the sport's
biggest showcase
reports suggest that qatar's 1.2 million
migrant workers are being exploited and
what are at times deadly working
conditions the british newspaper the
guardian recently said that up to 200
workers may have died on building sites
in the country
since the beginning of last year
and workers have also complained about
inhumane conditions off the job saying
they have been treated little better
than slaves
the chairman of the country's official
human rights committee says the
information is false and claims that
reports of poor treatment are
exaggerated
so is the 2022 world cup being built at
the expense of the exploited
that's the question
we'd like to answer isn't it peter
yeah but i i think we should take into
account that most of the middle east has
been built on migrant workers shoulders
there would not be any dubai and
bucharest the tallest building in the
world there would not be any formula one
race tracks in bahrain without nepalese
indian and bangladeshi workers so um
it's been there all the time but now you
know the world starts to look a little
closer at the problem you have said that
um you doubt that the 2022 world cup
will take place through the lens of a
free press
it will take place i don't think they're
going to push it they might be pushing
it to winter but not losing it
thought about what about being reported
freely and fairly that is not going to
happen in that country i think not from
the point now
we got nine years ahead of us that might
change you know the pressure that the
world builds up on qatar might change
things but right now it's not a country
of free speech you know you just got
back
from qatar you went over and you wanted
to report and find out
you know what's going on we were there
on an undercover mission obviously
because with the government issued
permission we wouldn't have you know
have the chance to talk to workers and
human rights people on the ground there
so we went in there undercover and
basically got we were tracked by the
state security uh from the first minute
we got into the country we were only
shooting with a very small photo camera
type of
equipment and and they were
tracking us all the way throughout the
city okay which you can live with but
then things changed when
exactly
on day two we were in our hotel i was
taping some uh some stand ups on the uh
on the balcony uh when the
knock on the door and some gentleman
introduced themselves as the federal
state police wanting to have a chat with
us there was the expression and that
chat turned out to be a five-hour
interrogation
in the headquarters of the federal state
police and
after taking all the memory cards from
us all our equipment the passports
naturally as well and we were then being
handed over to what i understand is the
state security police
something you know we over here in
germany have had uh
our times with bad bad experience with
did you think at this point though
i mean were you afraid did you think
okay yeah when the state security took
over we know this is getting serious me
i've been you know
having my bit of talks with the police
people all over the world shooting and
maybe some footage being taken away from
us but this is all because you were
shooting a stand-up on your balcony in
your hotel room well the official charge
wasn't even told you know that we
weren't told the official charge until
late at night in one of the
interrogations uh one of the shakes
mentioned that it might be a sparking an
upheaval that's this uh the expression
he used so talking to the workers would
have been uh you know sparkling it on
people down there which is totally
which is ridiculous we were talking to
indeed a couple of workers down there to
getting the same stories like the el the
uh the journalist from the guardian
getting the same stories of uh rundown
uh accommodations down there
problems with the kafala system which is
a sponsorship system forcing every
worker to you know hand out his
passports and basically all his rights
so what brought the interrogation to um
to an end the german
well the german what embassy had to get
involved right well we were put into
jail and we were held in jail for 21
hours
a number of interrogations taken place
down there uh in a very uh
secret state service type of room as far
as i can recall and just after 21 hours
foreign ministry uh german embassy got
involved and really pushed hard to uh
get his release okay we've got some of
the um footage of what you shot we want
to show the viewers there um and
obviously it's in german
but walk was through it it's the point
of time when we were had already been
released and the
material you see here the equipment on
our hotel bed had been given back to us
we were wondering if they had erased
anything from those hard disks and
apparently this is their little plastic
bag here with our memory cards in there
and uh it was a weekend we have to take
that into account well you look like
you're you know
you physically that you're okay oh yeah
we were okay we were treated kindly and
all right even though it was a jail a
very serious jail
but as a matter of fact uh
all our cards were given back to us with
the footage on it so
they had but they had checked what was
on it right definitely checked was they
even have checked they checked the the
photo camera itself made some test
charts and they're uh at their desks and
i i think they just didn't have the
enough time to you know maybe erase some
of the stuff in there when they let you
go did they did they say anything did
you they invited us back they invited us
to stay a couple of more days to you
know get the real side of the story as
they put it and you know i didn't refuse
in the first one i said well i i will be
back and maybe next time having the
chance to get the really angles we want
for that type of story you know getting
into the camps of the of the laborers
getting onto the sites and you know
getting a personal impression of how
they work there i mean
shouldn't we really be more than upset
that the world cup is is taking place in
a country where something like this can
happen we should have been to be honest
we should have been upset
throughout the last couple of years when
dubai flourished when bahrain had his
you know racetrack built in there nobody
spoke up there
and right now i think it's the highest
time to do that you know we got nine
years ahead of us we got qatar won't get
away with the you know interior policies
like this forever
i read somewhere that um qatar is a rich
country obviously and the average income
of of indigenous qataris is about 100
000 or something and for those migrants
workers it's 2 500 or something well the
migrant workers make up about 90 percent
of the population right yeah it's 330
000 qataris versus 1.5 million right
right so so yeah no wonder they're
scared of the riots really outrageous
that such a big gap between uh qataris
who live there who are qataris and those
those new police and philippine migrant
workers that's the big point all the
human rights activities uh
people make down there and all over the
world that situation has to change but
the qatari government won't let human
rights people you know do their job in
there why do you think so that your
material was not
erased to be honest it was a weekend it
was a saturday when we got uh uh uh into
the jail and i think that is the very
simple reason why they didn't have any
of the time they didn't have enough time
yes um we we also you know we're just we
have a few minutes before the end of the
show um what is happening right now is
there are confirmed cases of
construction workers dying from heat
exhaustion
no access to water
but there are also examples of people
not being paid right
that is the bigger problem from my
perspective i think that you know for
the formula one racetrack and for dubai
there has been a death toll you know for
every building and every building site
which is sadly sad enough but the
biggest problem down there is the
so-called caffala the sponsoring system
that exists originally to control the
amount the big amounts of workers coming
in there you know like a country with
that 300 000
in population can handle 1.5 million
workers so they they are obliged to have
a sponsor taken care of them medically
legally
i'm also taking their passions their
passports away okay but that also then
makes the migrant workers indebted
absolutely right so this is like
indentured servitude if it's not it's
like it serves that's the medieval term
i think yeah you know
you know and they don't try to hide it
it's an official system everybody talks
about it
so it's nothing the qatari government is
you know seems to be willing to change
right now what about before we wrap
things up fifa in all of this
why isn't fifa saying something
do you think they should there's too
much political money in it i think that
they thought i mean i think they
went down there to to check if
everything is all right but they should
do more i think they should really yeah
you were talking about accountability
right obviously absolutely that that's
that's that's needed here and
particularly because we have human
rights violations and that should
trigger
any international organization like fifa
to have a point and to stress that with
the government to make sure that any
system which is in place doesn't create
dependencies and doesn't create
violations of rights fifa already has
blood on its hands oh blatter's saying
you know in the press conference
statement you know
it's our responsibility to you know put
up a nice tournament in a safe
tournament but not directly workers
exactly and that's just a
misunderstanding very quickly will you
go back to qatar i will find out more
about the real truth and maybe knows you
know pushing it to a little change all
right well stay safe if you do that's
going to wrap up
this edition of agenda with brent goff
remember you can contact me anytime with
your thoughts on the show and you can
find me on facebook and you can tweet me
at brentgoth tv you can also email us
you see the address there on the screen
and if you want to watch the show again
go to dw's website or you can watch us
on youtube i'm brent goff in berlin join
us next time when i set the agenda
you